speaking of complete stupidity here's
joe scarborough on msnbc having a
complete mental breakdown over a bunch
of assorted stuff can you look
oh at the head-to-head matchup with ron
desantis the great white hope the guy
that we hear every day oh yeah from the
right man florida man from the right oh
he's going to win drawn to santa he's
strong
ron desantis he really showed the press
oh he really he really showed the
teachers oh he's banning books now he's
really showing people who like the first
submit and we hear that new takeaways
here joe top of which is excellent
impersonation typing as a foxnews.com uh
correspondent there um i think that
first of all i think there is a sense
we've talked about it during the show
there is a frustration among some
democrats toward this white house a
sense of eternal gratitude to joe biden
for defeating donald trump in 2020 but
thinking perhaps he's not the right guy
to now defeat trumpism and that maybe by
issues
more americans agree with what the
democrats are than where the republicans
are the crackpots in arizona that are
lining up that looks like they're going
to be nominated uh to run there they're
conspiracy theorists they're weirdos
they're freaks uh
they're they're um
you know they are the most unelectable
uh and yet they've risen to the top in
each of these republican primaries i
know that mitch mcconnell has to be
pulling his hair out because this should
be easy republicans are making a lot
harder than it should be
well i hate to tell you
joe scarborough joe scarborough who's
taken every position on everything often
got everything wrong nobody knows what
you honestly believe about anything he's
referring there to blake masters my
friend who's been on the show
who is going to be the next senator from
arizona and he's also referring there to
carrie lake who's been on the show who's
going to be the next governor of arizona
and he's calling them unelectable and uh
mark my words people uh they're both
gonna win and they're both gonna
deservingly win uh and the idea that
they're freaks and weirdos and and
unelectable and conspiracy theorists and
all of these things uh is completely
insane blake his platform is so freaking
clean and clear and crisp on top of the
fact that he's a good dude he's exactly
what we need in politics he's a young
guy with a family three kids he's a good
father and a decent man he was in the
tech world for years one of peter
thiel's top guys he did not need to go
into politics but he's going in because
he wants to protect his state and
protect this country he wants there to
be a safe border he wants law and order
and a whole bunch of other things his
democrat opponent by the way mark kelly
uh he wants to pack the supreme court um
but you know i get it joe scarborough is
just is just sort of a nut bag and msnbc
is a televised mental institution